Simon Morel author of the poet in the
murder what's your book about it's about
a forged Emily Dickinson poem that was
bought by the Jones library in Amherst
they believed it was a genuine poem it
was spotted by the curator of Special
Collections at the Jones library in
April 1997 in a Sotheby's catalog it was
advertised as a genuine Emily Dickinson
poem it was a 15 line poem and the first
unpublished Emily Dickinson poem in 40
years which was quite an event it's the
manuscripts are very rare and very
valuable and there hadn't been a new
poem on the market for some 40 years so
we're in Amherst at the moment yep the
stories library that's right the story
starts in Amherst which of course it
should be noted is Emily Dickinson's
birthplace so the discovery of this
brand-new poem which was up for sale at
Sotheby's at the June 1997 auction was a
big event for Amherst and above all for
the curator of special collections there
it has a his desire to buy it was
motivated not just by wanting to add to
the collection that they have of
manuscripts including Dickinson
manuscripts Robert Frost of course lived
in Amherst they have a number of those
it's also loaded motivated by a desire
to bring this poem home if you like and
Daniel Lombardo who was the curator who
organized a fundraising drive to raise
the money the Jones library is not a
very wealthy Lively compared with
Harvard or Yale some of the big
privately endowed libraries and it was a
battle for this little town library it's
actually the local librarian in Amherst
it's not the Amherst College Library
it's actually the town's public library
but it has this Special Collections
section where they have a pretty good
collection of original manuscripts
related to writers connected with
adverse so for him it was an exciting
moment it was the chance to bring this
wonderful new Emily Dickinson poem home
to Amherst
on the back a book you have a picture of
Emily Dickinson that's right
why why is her poetry so valuable she's
a great poet and her reputation I think
it's fair to say has risen progressively
since her death in 1880
she was regarded for a long time as just
being too difficult and eccentric in
terms of the way that she wrote it's a
very modern expressionist sort of
idiosyncratic way of writing much more
like a Cummings than 19th century poets
and for a long time I think the public
just had a lot of trouble with these
short very complex poems that she wrote
starting in I guess the 1920s then
progressively through the 50s a big
edition came out the forties and fifties
her reputation began to soar and really
in the last 25 years above all her
reputation has really soared and she's
now regarded I think it's Harold Bloom
that the literary critic that has said
that is in his opinion she's one of the
two great American greatest American
poets and I'll let you guess who the
other one is no Walt Whitman
so she's overtaken if you like a lot of
other candidates or potential candidates
for being now regarded as one of the two
great American poet Ian you went to her
home there in Amherst yes that's right
and the homestead it's called which has
been preserved as a museum and renovated
they've now renovated the house next
door the evergreens where her brother
and sister-in-law lived it was an
extraordinary a world that she inhabited
and a very reclusive person she lived at
home in the homestead which was a large
one of the larger houses it was very
well-to-do family to Dickinson family
one of the best families in Amherst old
New England Yankee family Emily ended up
staying at home really all of her life
except for a couple of short visits and
indeed for the last some 2530 years of
her life she never left the grounds of
the house and she lived there and worked
there wrote her poetry in her bedroom
upstairs and for anybody who hasn't been
there it's really well worth going it's
a bit like you know I think all writers
houses are interesting and they're
certainly when you go up the stairs and
you go into the bedroom you can see the
bed that she slept in all of those years
on the table by the window where she
wrote these extraordinary poems none of
which of course were published I mean
she was a she left a great riddle and a
great mystery to the world when she died
she was herself a great riddle and a
great mystery in her life because she
was so rarely seen you know she dressed
in white frequently she was rarely
glimpsed she almost never went into the
town she was a recluse Howard Hughes's
the wrong comparison but she was as
reclusive as Howard Hughes certainly how
long did she live and when did she die
she was born in 1830 and died in 1883 I
think it isn't sorry if I get the date
wrong but she she died in you know late
40s of complications with her kidneys
and what impacted her to have on her
life in her poetry and her image that
she never married well that's an
interesting question I have not thought
about that I think in a life it had none
at all because she wasn't known as a
poet except to a very small collection
of friends and supporters she had a
number of friends who were editors of
literary journals or newspapers and they
knew of her work but she didn't get it
published it was really just it was a
hundred years ahead of the times her
poems were so modern in their sound and
so unlike the kind of poetry was that
was being written during her lifetime
that she didn't find an audience at that
time so she was really except for a
small
number of people she was entirely
unknown to the public that changed soon
after her death but her reputation
it took quite a long time for it to
really become established and and and
for the facts about her life to become
clear and they never have actually
because she left so little evidence of
who she was
apart from these extraordinary powers
that were found in a locked box you know
this was a secret activity for her the
writing of poetry was her private
confessional if you like it's where she
wrote down all of the things that moved
her and she cared about most how many
bombs did she write she wrote I think
the numbers 1789 something like that 7
1789 yeah I think 700 were found in this
lock box that and then another 1089 were
found elsewhere some of them had been
sent to friends in letters or just as
gifts she wrote poems
you know if after somebody had died she
sent a consoling note and often a little
poem and none of them had titles none of
them had dates and only 10 of them had
been published in her lifetime
and those against her will so when she
died the world her family initially and
then the world discovered this really
it's one of the great literary riddles
of the world actually is when were these
poems written and to whom were they
written because as I say in the book if
you look at a writer like William
Wordsworth in England because he was
published and the poems appeared at
specific dates and had titles and were
written about him in reviews you can
establish a chronology of the writers
life you know when William Wordsworth
wrote lines written above Tinton Abbey
you know how old he was what he what was
going on in his life why he wrote the
poem none of this is no
I've had Emily Dickinson one page for
your book that God cannot be understood
everyone agrees we did not know his
motives nor comprehend his deeds then
why should I seek solace and what I
cannot know better to play and Wintersun
than to fear the snow what's that
that is the forgery that is a poem that
was forged by Mark Hofmann an
extraordinarily gifted forger also a
double murderer and hence the title of
the book the poet and the murderer and
that was the poem that was that appeared
in the Sotheby's catalog in April 1997
and it was seen by the curator of the
Jones library it's a 15 line poem the
date that the forger hop mark Hoffman
ascribed to his 1871 which is important
big cars Emily Dickinson was what 40 41
at that time and she was writing these
kinds of poems had great years as an
artist in most prolific years and the
years at which she wrote her greatest
poetry for which she's remembered with
this sort of late eighteen fifties early
sixties 1862 s for there's a little bit
after that her talent started to cool a
little bit her production started to
lessen as well and she did less revision
of her poems and she wrote these kind of
little homily pieces with which this is
it's not when the experts looked at it
when Daniel Lombardo looked at it and
then asked Ralph Franklin at Yale
University to have a look at it at it as
Daniel Lombardo was thinking of buying
the poem he wanted a outside opinion and
he took it to somebody called Ralph
Franklin who was the head of the binary
library in Yale at Yale University and
Franklin is the world's acknowledged
expert on Dickinson's manuscripts her
handwriting the whole publication
history
the history of her workshop as its
called and Franklin looked at the poem
and both he and Lombardo felt it wasn't
a great poem you know it was I think the
best comment I heard was if this was
Emily it was Emily on a bad day but she
did write other poems around this time
and later that were not you know there
were little homilies there so called
wisdom pieces and that led them to think
well okay the country in terms of the
content it could be an Emily Dickinson
play so far we have Amherst
Massachusetts the Jones library is it a
private libraries at a local public
library it's a public library funded
partly well partly brought by the town
of Amherst and partly by donation for
the special collection you get Ralph
Franklin who is with the by Nikki
library rare books and all that at yes
right then how does both Salt Lake City
and Las Vegas come into this right well
the press I should go back to the
beginning of the story how I've got to
find out about it I read a little
article in The New York Times that said
this poem had been found and it was the
first unpublished Emily Dickinson for 40
years it was going on sale and it was a
half a page article had talked about
Dickinson her reputation some of those
things we've been talking about they
didn't really think twice about it I
happened to read it six months later I
read a very small piece in The New York
Times that said the unpublished Emily
Dickinson poem recently purchased by the
Jones live in Amherst for twenty-one
thousand dollars has been returned to
Sotheby's as a forgery so go back to
there for a second the New York Times
had bought off on the idea that this was
a real pump everybody had so they bid a
big article and Sotheby's is involved
selling it the new york-based sale that
they were gonna have yeah and so up till
that point every I thought this is a
real thing and your friend Dan Lombardo
who has the Jones library was gonna buy
this thing absolutely and the probably
the the the main reason that he was
satisfied he did you know his own so
called due diligence he looked at the
poem he looked
other poems that Jones lied we had
genuine Emily Dickinson poems one I
think we've got on the table called a
little madness and spring which comes
from the same day this play this is
actually a photocopy of a genuine
Dickinson writing in pawn famous poem
the first Jones library owned from much
the same date and the first thing that
Dan Lombardo did was to compare the
letter forms the writing to handwriting
of the poem that God cannot be
understood with this poem and Ralph
Franklin did so also and I think it's
safe to say that Lombardo decided to buy
the poem because Ralph Frankland a great
expert if anybody in America if anybody
in the world would know what is a
genuine Emily Dickinson poem based above
all on the handwriting the content was
good enough it wasn't great but it could
be Emily Dickinson above all it was that
it was the handwriting and Franklin at
Yale University took the poem that
turned out to be a forgery and he has
charts of letter forms or the examle
Dickinson's handwriting this is one of
the interesting kind of puzzles in the
whole story changed enormous Lee during
her lifetime indeed if you compare
manuscripts from when she was in her 20s
to manuscripts at the end of her life
you would barely believe that the same
person had written these poems and very
cleverly the forger in a sense it shows
the greatness of the forgery he chosen a
time 1871 where her handwriting was
particularly complicated
Ralph Franklin has described as her
handwriting was coming apart she was
writing she had trouble with eyesight at
that time and she had hypertension and
that may have affected how she wrote and
you'll find different letter forms that
she used for instance a letter e small e
which she used before 1871 and then
after which she used a different form
after Hayden
21 there's one small he looks like a
normal and then there's another he that
looks like a 3 turn backwards it doesn't
look like it what you and I with the
smoke caller Smalley at all
both of these letter e's occurred in
this poem and so when Franklin went to
look at his charts with all of the
letters he was finding well good you
know here's this letter e
here's that form there was two forms of
the letter D everything checked out
everything that the letter T was right
the way she wrote at H was right not
just generally right but minutely and
specifically right for 1871 so when he
looked at this he thought god damn it
you know this has to be genuine Franklin
and imagining talking now this has to be
genuine because as he felt nobody and
the world could possibly know these
details about her handwriting except him
actually the book the poet and the
murder the poet is Emily Dickinson the
murder is Mark Hofmann where is he today
he's in a medium-security prison in
Draper Utah mark Hoffman was a Mormon
brought up in Salt Lake City very bright
very gifted young man was a teenager was
interested in chemistry and history
science he went to Logan State
University had studied biology very
interested in science chess very
rational mind enquiring mind but he was
brought up in a very strict Mormon
environment and he became disgruntled
with the Mormon Church he had a lot of
questions about what he regarded were
problem areas of Mormon doctrine and
theology to put it bluntly he simply
didn't believe many of the founding
legends of the Mormon religion
and he was also very troubled by a
family secret that there was his
grandmother had been married in a
polygamous marriage after the time that
polygamy had been bad and it was a sort
of a family to boo to talk about it and
he became obsessed by this his own story
the story of his own family he wanted to
find out what was the truth about his
grandmother's marriage and nobody wanted
to talk about it his family refused to
talk about it the community-at-large
refused to discuss it because of course
polygamy has been a very problematic
institution legacy for the Mormon Church
and I think that this inquiring young
mind that had a lot of questions like
all teenagers you know I have a teenage
son and full of questions and the most
important thing with teenagers I think
is to you keep a dialogue open and there
wasn't really he was told you know shut
up and believe it's a paraphrase it
slightly crudely
and I think that generated a great deal
of resentment in him he became a twisted
person inside I think he also became a
person who was forced to become one
thing on the outside while he was
actually another thing on the inside and
he began to Forge Mormon documents which
at first he was a brilliant conman and a
master of human psychology one of the
great Criminal Minds actually I think of
the 20th century he knew what people
wanted he it was as though he could look
inside your heart and tell what it was
that you cared about most certainly in
terms of manuscript collecting he knew
what people wanted and he created
documents that would answer that that
need you say in the book or you quote
somebody the book is saying that he
forged a thousand documents that's right
and solve them that's right he as far as
we know because the full tally isn't
isn't in but as far as we know it's
about a thousand
doc how old is he today he is in his
late 40s and he's in prison yeah he was
sentenced to prison in 1986 for murder
he eventually his career as a forger he
created these thousand documents
initially they were above all Mormon
documents and what he did was
diabolically cunning he initially
created documents that appeared to
authenticate some of the central tenets
of the Mormon religion Mormonism is
you're probably knows was had a bit of a
problem because it has not had
historical proof of some of its founding
legends and myths which is unusual for
such a young religion I mean it's normal
that things from the Christian early
Christian era have disappeared but
Mormonism dates back to the 19th century
but we don't really have any part facts
and documents to prove its founding
legends and there was always a worry
within the mormon hierarchy that this
was the case and there was a great
hunger for what they called faith
promoting documents documentation that
could prove that what was said in the
Book of Mormon was true and what Hofmann
knew the culture grew up in it he began
to create documents that appeared to
support central parts of the Mormon
legend to give you an example
he he he forged the what would have been
the first Mormon artifact a letter from
the Prophet Joseph Smith's mother he
forged the last which was a letter from
Joseph Smith written in prison these are
for the Mormon Church he's a huge huge
documents you know and he forged
something called the Anton transcript
it's too complicated to get into but for
the Mormon Church these were
extraordinary it would be a bit like
finding a new letter bison pool and I
don't exaggerate here you know for the
Christian religion
and he sold these to the Mormon Church
and thereby won their confidence he was
also himself a well respected dealer of
historical documents in Salt Lake City
genuine historical documents which he
used then as a front and he amassed the
Mormon Church and its hierarchy and it's
worth noting here that the president of
the Mormon Church
Gordon B Hinckley who was involved with
many of these transactions has a figure
in the Mormon religion a bit like the
Pope in Roman Catholicism Hoffman was
eventually dealing on one-on-one terms
with Gordon Hinckley who thought of
course that he was buying genuine
documents you say that the Mormon Church
has 12 million people in it were a wise
Road go back to again the date thing
he's been in prison you say since 1986
six the Amherst library purchased was
1997 that's right now where were you
when you first read that in the art time
story I was a home on Long Island having
breakfast and read the story about this
Emily Dickinson poem turned up because
nothing was known about Mark Hofmann
there was no connection and as I said I
didn't really note it and then I read a
second article that said it was a
forgery and I remember putting down the
paper and turning to my wife and saying
who would do such a thing who could do
such a thing
then I remembered the first article well
what were you doing for a living well
I'm a full-time journalist I'm a
magazine writer and of course you always
you know as a magazine writer you have
your antenna up for a great story and I
just was intrigued by this and thought
who could manage that who would you know
he'd fooled Sotheby's he fooled the
Jones library he fooled everybody
whoever this was if it was a forger
which it was and I called up dan
Lombardo the curator of the Jones
library who had bought the poem and then
done his own as suspicions arose dan and
one of the stories I tell in the book
it's the story of a small town like
arian who thinks he's doing the best
thing for his you know little home
library and finds he's a meshed in this
extraordinary story of money forgery
auction houses rare documents dealer in
las vegas gun dealers in Salt Lake City
and the trail eventually leads back to
mark Hoffman to a prison cell in Utah
and when I heard the outlines of the
story from Daniel Lombardo the first 45
minutes over the phone I mean I had that
you know classic the hair stand up on
your back of your neck I just couldn't
believe that behind this Emily Dickinson
poem and there was a tyranny to me
immediately of course here's this most
reclusive were closest reclusive sorry
of people who didn't publish in her
lifetime
who called publication publication is
the auction of the mind of man of all
people she became the object of this
extraordinary convoluted literary scam
and I was just fascinated by all of the
multiple levels of it and I tried in the
book to tell you know all of these
different stories the story of Emily
Dickinson the story of mark Hoffman
Daniel Lombardo's story and to to mesh
them together if you like and the more
mature and the Mormon Church because you
couldn't tell mark Hofmann's story
without looking at the culture that he
grew up in which shaped him in a in a
deformed kind of way now you're from
where originally I'm British yep
already read well I was an army brat so
I grew up aged six months I was shipped
off on a on a plane to East Africa and
then Paris and then Singapore came back
to England when I was nine and Wendy was
the first time you came to the United
States where I came first in 73 just
travelling as a young I just graduated
from college but I'd always had a sort
of relationship always been interested
in America and America
can myth and American literature and
studied literature at college and I
lived in Germany for a number of years
in the 80s and then I met my now wife in
the early nineties and moved over here
and you know became a correspondent
magazine writer writing all-american
stories for European publications most
are you still a bracer sir yes sir and
you live here full time since I live
here full time since 91
yes 1991 yeah so this is five years ago
when you got into all this have you met
mark Hoffman no despite repeated
attempts he's about as reclusive and
secretive as Emily Dickinson and he we
tried the the book originated as a
magazine story that was commissioned by
Harper's Magazine in New York and what
year this is 1998 that kind of time 1999
I wrote the first story and it had a
tangled publication history Harper's
couldn't bring it down to a length that
we thought worked it was then bought by
The New Yorker the New Yorker walked
away from it eventually and I won't get
into too much detail on that but they
were worried that Sotheby's were going
to sue them which I don't think they
would have it was eventually picked up
the article god bless him by George
Plimpton at the Paris Review who we had
to do a lot of legal very thorough legal
vetting and I remember having to write
answer 290 questions from Clinton's
lawyer because there was a lot of legal
issues at stake and the book doesn't
quite prove that Sotheby's knew this
they were selling a forgery by a double
murderer but it certainly asks a lot of
questions about what they did know and I
leave it to the audience the reader to
decide what it is you know what they did
or didn't know and since you're the
bookseller bees has had its own problem
since this other bees has had its own
very great problems of course the former
chairman of Sotheby's Alfred aide Talman
is currently in the same situation as
Mark Hofmann
he's in a federal penitentiary for the
price fixing what became known as the
price fixing scandal commission's fixing
and i think in a sense that that says a
lot about the kind of culture i can't
speak about and know what i want to
comment on how it is now but i think
it's safe to say that now what what we
know about what the chairman of
Sotheby's was doing that was illegal for
which he's in jail I think it's fair to
say that as most companies reflect the
habits and behavior of their CEOs
whether it's Enron or Sotheby's I think
it's fair to say that the culture of
Sotheby's at that time was not quite as
actually said honest as it could have
been did you ever ask the Maritimes why
they believed this was a real pawn no I
didn't actually I didn't I I think they
had no reason to wonder why why it
wasn't but it was they had taken that
from Celebes with that they would have
taken it from Sotheby's here it was in
the Sotheby's catalog that seemed to be
you know sufficient reason it looked
like an Emily Dickinson poem and I I
suppose they were generally satisfied
that Sotheby's had done its due
diligence and their experts had decided
it was authentic and ipso facto it was
who owns Sotheby's Sotheby's is owned
well I think it's about to be sold
actually isn't it because Alfred
a-tellin was both the chairman and the
owner of Sotheby's but originally a
British company originated British
company absolutely founded in the late
18th century it's very interesting there
and is one of the stories I tell in
brief a sort of snapshot history of
Sotheby's is one of the interesting
things is you know in the early days of
Sotheby's foundation in in London in the
18th century which was a fairly raffish
century probably our most you know
raffish the auction houses were regarded
in a very poor light they were regarded
as you know basically secondhand
salesman of old people's old furniture
and paintings and honesty was not
something they were associated and they
certainly weren't associated with
glamour they were sort of yard sales
glory
five yard sales and of course our age
obsessed as it is with celebrity has
sort of transformed that and the auction
houses have been very clever into
transforming themselves into you know
icons of high life really you know to go
to a Sotheby's sale or a Christie's sale
now but whether you buy a Vermeer or a
van Gogh or not is regarded much the
same as you know having a seat at the
best restaurant in New York or you know
going to watch polo in Bridgehampton so
did anybody ever publish this in
magazine form yes it came out in the
Paris Review thank just the person he
finally got to that yes thanks to George
Plimpton who loved the story and
actually called it Emily Dickinson goes
to Las Vegas which I thought was great
because one of the connections one of
the back stories was that the document
the poem had passed through the hands of
a historical documents dealer in Las
Vegas of all places not a place that's
really known for historical documents or
or its culture but more for gambling
obviously it had passed through the
hands of historical documents dealer
they're called Todd Axelrod and it was
discovered by Dan Lombardo and later by
myself that had have been in Axelrod's
possession for a number of years he did
exhibit it in his showrooms for sale for
$40,000
then the trails that went cold and years
later it popped up at Sotheby's and
incidentally one of the great the
initial article was a sort of piece of
detective work it was true connecting
all of the dots we had a sort of a
skeleton structure of how this poem had
got from mark Hofmann's hands a double
murderer currently in jail in Utah var
Las Vegas to Sotheby's in New York and
to the Jones library in Amherst and one
of the reasons the story fascinated me
was this extraordinary journey across
America that this document had taken and
passed through these different hands and
the initial article that the main thrust
of it was to join the dots together how
did it get from Hoffman to Las Vegas
from Las Vegas to Sotheby's what did
Sotheby's know
what did the dealer in Las Vegas know
who was telling the truth was anyone
what's his more information in this book
than there was in the article much more
about what basically what what kind of
things are new in the book in the book
well obviously when I got in advance
from penguin Putnam Dutton who published
a book and had a year to write the book
and one of the first questions you're
asked is you know why what's in this
that could make a book why do we want to
know more about this and really what
what has become expanded greatly is the
role both of Emily Dickinson
her life story which is a parallel story
of in a way almost secret identity in a
way that mark Hofmann's is there's much
more about the Mormon Church there's
much more about the history of for
literary forgery which I became
fascinated in and as I tried to tell a
lot of different stories but to keep the
story moving forward fast as a chapter I
do on handwriting it became fascinated
in the neuropsychology of handwriting
the complexity you know every time we
pick up a pen and a piece of paper it's
extraordinary complex process that's
involving 50 muscles in our shoulder arm
and hands and neuro neurological
reactions and so I wanted to tell Lots
as many different stories as I could in
the book as I read the book I kept
saying okay who do you murder who do you
murder who do you murder Hannah you you
don't tell us for a long time use it on
purpose yes of course
yes of course you want to tell our
audience we murder no I think I'll leave
it for them to go and buy the book and
how much did you decide before you sat
down to do interviews that you would not
tell an audience like this and they were
like this yeah not much actually but
that that I I did I did give that away
several times and I you know it's just
it's better that the reader discovers
that it does take a long time and you
did you do that on purpose
yes absolutely I mean every writer does
that whether you know whether it's a
nonfiction book or a novel of course
there's you know you delay the the
climax of the book if you like and it
not that that is that the the soul
climax and to go back to that thing
about
what changed in the book the real
breakthrough with the writing of the
book and where it took on a new
dimension and became much more as I hope
it is then a long magazine article and I
don't think it is a it's it's a book was
when I started to see these uncanny
parallels between the two main
characters the poet and the murder and
that's what I need to say of course I am
in no sense of waiting mark Hoffman a
forger a forger and a murderer with
Emily Dickinson but they do have one
thing in common and I think it's why one
of the reasons I was fascinated by both
of them and I think people will be
interested when they read the book is
we're all fascinated by genius whether
it's Michael Jordan you know shooting
three-pointers or a great ballet dancer
or a great painter or a great writer
were all fascinated by those people that
seem to have some extra superhuman
talent Emily Dickinson certainly did
very very great wonderful wonderful poem
poet who I one of the pleasures is right
in the book was finding out a lot about
her mark Hoffman was also a genius he's
in my opinion the greatest literary
forger that has ever been and there is a
long history of literary forgery ever
since man first picked up actually a
papyrus read and scratched on it and we
go back to that you're saying he's the
greatest forger in history hmm how do
you make that determination well I I
think the the variety of then not the
volume he did a thousand documents which
is a lot but there was a great French
literary forger in the nineteenth
century who did many more than that I
think something like thirty thousand the
extraordinary number so it's not the
volume it's the quality and the variety
and you know just to sort of backtrack a
bit for the viewers you know I think
we're all more familiar as I was when I
came to this story with lit without
forgery there's been some very famous
art forger van Meter
who did the familiars and many others
books have been written but literary
forgers have not been so extensively
covered and it's a fascinating sort of I
came to think of it as a sort of
parallel world of literary creativity
because they're very gifted people who
invent poems or documents they can
simulate the handwriting they alter the
paper shuffle was a great technician so
it's not the quantity it's the quality
and the technical skill he most literary
foragers they specialize you know as
most art forgers do they do Vermeer or
they do Monet literary for jurors tend
to specialize as well they'll do if it's
an American forger there was a very
great one in the 19th century called
Joseph cosey little Battaglia our
American lived in New York did great
great forgeries fooled everybody
everybody he did a what would have been
the original manuscript of posed a raven
or a working copy of it got everything
right Edgar Allan Poe's hand right into
paper everything but that most forgers
have tended to specialize they choose
one thing they do Lincoln or they do
Daniel Boone or they do Edgar Allan Poe
because they get good at that one thing
and then they stick with that Hoffman as
far as we know did a hundred and thirty
different handwriting's and not just
clip signatures but sustained documents
Lincoln George Washington everybody I
mean he forged all of the great figures
of the Mormon Church Joseph Smith
Brigham Young Lucy Smith the prophets
mother and the list goes on and on
they found a list in his prison cell in
1989 in Utah which where he listed the
Mormon forgeries and his non-mormons
forgeries and on the list of non-mormon
forgeries he did there is every iconic
American figure of Abraham Lincoln
George Washington Martha Washington
Myles Standish Daniel Boone Abraham
Lincoln
and forth down on that list that was
found was the name Emily Dickinson who
is that person that caught him well he
was and again I don't want to give too
much away he was he he he murdered two
people he was about to be exposed or he
believed he was about to be exposed as a
fortune and as a fraudulent he was a con
man as well he ran what are called Ponzi
schemes using historical documents he
would take money for documents he hadn't
produced he would take money to buy
documents that were going to be worth a
huge amount of money then he wouldn't
deliver the documents and then you know
he would run these schemes and like all
criminals he you know he started to get
too clever and he thought he could never
be caught and he started to get reading
and one of the curious things about
Hoffman was that his Achilles heel if
you like and every criminal has some
fatal flaw his was that he was a
passionate collector of children's
historical children's books above all
British children's books he had when he
went to prison he had America's finest
collection of historic children's books
above all he had a first edition of the
Lord of the Rings signed by Tolkien he
had the first edition of The Adventures
of Sherlock Holmes extraordinary he had
Enid Enid Blyton books he had Beatrix
Potter books signed by the author of all
the strange things you know this was his
obsession actually he was collecting
them to leave to his children and he was
spending is actually hid the roots of
his downfall whether he was himself
buying at auction and at Sotheby's among
others large numbers of genuine first
editions this was his passion he was a
Biblio main as they're called somebody
who's maniacally obsessed with old books
I loved them had a genuine love of them
and above all children's book
and he amassed this extraordinary action
and he was spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars at auction buying
these things and of course his forgeries
he couldn't produce them fast enough to
to pay for all of the books he was
buying the genuine documents and he
started to cut out the corners he was
about to be exposed and he savagely
murdered two people with pipe bombs and
he was then arrested on suspicion of
those but to prove he was a murderer
they had to first prove that he was a
forger that there was a motive for the
murders and the motive was the forgery
and they could not at first find any
sign of forgery in the documents they
had been incidentally one of his great
forgeries the oath of a Freeman which
would have been if it were genuine the
first piece of printed Americana the
first document printed on the North
American continent in 1638 often forged
it it was nearly bought by the Library
of Congress here in Washington for 1
million dollars
after they had bombarded it you know
with all of the expertise they had it
that document passed a carbon-14 dating
test to the crocker nuclear laboratory
in davis california
it was that good by the way has anybody
come after you
legally no yeah no not yet no oh my god
I don't think so
I don't think so Sotheby's don't doesn't
sue people because it did I hope I'm not
proved wrong it just doesn't want to go
to court and make things worse the
Mormon Church are they happy with you
but I don't know it's been reviewed in
the Mormon newspaper but the Deseret
News I thought it would get savaged and
it was a reasonably polite and friendly
review they did say that I did a hatchet
job on Salt Lake City and the painted a
outdated picture of the Mormon Church
but you know of course the thing about
that and I'd like to say that is I had
to look at the culture of
the Mormon Church from the inside from
the eyes so to speak through the eyes of
Mark Hofman did you talk to Gordon
Hinkley by the way president of the
church I didn't talk to anybody at the
Mormon Church talk to you no did you try
to talk to him no I didn't actually I
relied on my main source further for the
Mormon for the for the LDS account of
this whole episode very painful episode
in their modern history was a very very
good book that was written in the 80s by
Richard Turley called victims which was
a book commissioned by the LDS Church
and it had chapter on verse of all of
his Mormon forgeries and I relied you
know that was there in a sense that was
their official statement that was their
official summing up of this whole
painful event and I to be honest I
assume that Gordon B Hinckley would not
interview with me and if he did he
probably would not say anything that was
different from that also the audience
knows that what's what's going on here
again going back over he would take
forged documents to the church and say
you want this $40,000 and if they didn't
buy it that would go somewhere else and
then the public would see they would
undermine the church you basically would
in many cases prove that a lot of their
basic tenets of their religion aren't
accurate well it was more cynical and
devious than that and more Machiavellian
he first as you said he won the
confidence of the church producing
documents that appeared to authenticate
the religion having won the confidence
of the church his real his real goal and
he's unique in the long history of
literary forgery he intended to use
literary forgery forged documents to
bring down the Mormon Church to
discredit the Mormon Church and having
won their trust he began to produce
documents that called into question the
founding myths and legends of Mormonism
it would be as though a disgruntled
Catholic were to Forge letters by some
poll that proved that some poor was a
homicide
let's say they were that damaging to the
church then once once he would sell them
the documents and they bought them they
would be hidden away hidden away but
he'd leak it that they were there that
was that that was the ultimate he was a
spin-doctor long before one of the
things that interest me about Mark
Hofmann was the way that he prefigured a
lot of things that have become part of
our world subsequently spin doctoring
you know the image and reality we live
in an age of sort of shimmering surfaces
and I think he understood we were moving
into that age and he understood that
ultimately you know there is no
difference or if you're clever enough
and devious enough what there is no
difference between what something
genuine and something forged if it's
that good and indeed between who you are
on the outside who you appear to be and
who you are on the inside and he
understood something very deep about
human nature and he used that and
manipulated that and as you said
specific to go back to your question
having created documents that were
shattering for the Mormon Church if they
became public and they were taken they
were bought and then hidden away so that
people could not see these documents
Mark Hofman sort of you know stuck the
knife in even further by then leaking
the stories to the newspapers to the
press about the document that he had
just sold so the press then became it
became a news story about supposedly
this extraordinary document the
salamander letter the most famous of his
Mormon forgeries that became a news
story in itself that this document had
been found and then of course that put
the Mormon Church in an extraordinary
embarrassing position because they had
to then admit yes they had bought this
document and yes they had so to speak
kept it away from the public so they
were then if you like Hofmann wanted to
show prove that they manipulated history
that they manipulated reality and
history and he used forgery which is
itself a manipulation of history to do
that one of the things you point out is
that he went through the Mormon ritual
and was a missionary or
England but also went through something
called the endowment ceremony yeah
where'd you get the information on what
the endowment ceremony I these are very
secret as you know probably Mormon
rituals one of the things that Mormons
are sworn to is to is not reveal any of
the temple rituals which it yeah pretty
strange to say the least I think anybody
reading a book called and and reading my
account of the endowment Center ceremony
will be very surprised you know people
that sort of naked and in white sheets
and they have oil anointed on them and
it all sounds like something out of
ancient Rome or something not modern
America you know they're immersed in
water and and all of this I I got that
information actually from somebody in
Salt Lake City I think I'll choose not
to name the name but but somebody who's
an ex-mormon
and who has now devoted their time and
energy to telling what they regard is
the truth about Mormonism that you know
they're they're a dissident Mormon and
they make those things public because
they believe that both Mormons and
non-mormons have a right to know the
truth about this religion is there been
a book written it explains all the
handshake and the Dalman ceremony and
all that not so far as I know in that
you know so is this gonna be one of the
first times that people could read about
this that's right I believe so I believe
so this is a highly sensitive
information before we run out of time
couple quick things Dan Lombardo who was
the fellow that bought the original
Emily Dickinson poem forged poem for
$21,000 where is he now well it was one
of the the things I loved about the
story as I said earlier for me it was
the story partly of a small-town
librarian by as this wonderful document
thinks he's doing a great thing for his
hometown suddenly is it had mashed in
this world of deception and illusion and
money and forgery and gun dealers and a
double murderer
and Dan was a we became very close
through the course of writing this book
he was a great help to me and all power
to him some people perhaps when he began
to be suspicious of the poem might have
you know kept the truth about it hidden
but he relentlessly went on a mission to
find out what was the truth and
eventually established enough evidence
collected enough evidence to confront
Sotheby's they refunded the money but
the experience is his journey is very
interesting because it's the experience
for him buying this forgery and just at
finding that what he thought was going
to be the pinnacle of his career and the
best thing he ever did for his local
community turned out to be this awful
event and really he thought you know his
life was finished in Amherst and his
career as a curator would be finished
and he was deeply deeply disillusioned
by the whole series of events I mean
it's shattered all of his illusions
about the auction houses about the
manuscript trade and he threw up his job
and gave up the job and left and done at
one time was in pretty bad shape you
know he really felt that his life had
melted down but as it turned out this
came to be an opportunity and he started
a new life as a writer he's practicing
Zen Buddhism he's living on Cape Cod and
there's very very happy man so you know
in a sense I also wanted the book to be
a sort of morality tale not just another
true crime story about a you know an
interesting bad man but a sort of
morality tale and the book ends with
everybody I think getting there just
rewards Emily Dickinson wins eternal
fame Daniel Lombardo has a new life and
the forger is where he belongs
who's Doorly old Doorly old Doralee olds
was mark Hofmann's wife and you talked
to her old yes I did on two occasions
here's a picture of her we're back in
1988 at the hearings yeah it's in when
did she divorce him in 1989 after he'd
been sentenced and he was in jail
Darley olds olds is the maiden name as
she reverted to her maiden name once she
became too
yes I talked to her twice at length very
fascinating woman that and a woman I
felt very sympathetic towards their been
questions people have raised questions
about what she knew I didn't know I mean
Mark Hofmann did his forgeries in the
family house down in the basement and
people have said well how could this
woman not know you know what was going
on down in the basement that he was
creating these forgeries but I choose to
give Doorly the you know the benefit of
the doubt
and and there's a reason for that
specific to the to the culture that they
both lived in with which is that Mormon
wives are not expected to ask their
husbands questions about what they're
doing they're not expected actually to
ask their husbands questions about much
at all
let alone you know what are you doing
down in the basement honey so she was a
sort of a true faithful Mormon wife who
didn't didn't ask any of those questions
and I like to be and you could say I've
chosen to believe because she has
suffered enough and had a very very hard
time obviously I choose to believe that
she didn't know how much of all this
story was reported in the Deseret News
the Mormon newspaper oh the original
story Oh a huge amount a huge amount I
mean it was reported in Time magazine
the Hoffmann case of the Mormon
forgeries and 80s was a pretty big news
story it was on television when the
murders took place
it was in Time magazine it was it was a
big event because it was a as something
that involved the Mormon Church when it
came to the book you know that's the
only part of the story I tried to
concentrate on this this one forgery
this Emily Dickinson forgery and as I
said what the book took on a greater
depth when I discovered the strange
uncanny parallels between these two
people they both were one thing on the
outside Emily Dickinson was well-to-do
daughter of a leading family she was
another thing on the inside they were
both great at were very very you know
they were both geniuses at what they did
her writing poetry him forging these
documents and what interested me in
writing the book was to if you like to
to bring these to carry
just together a bit like electric wires
and and see what sparks would would fly
I hope I'm not giving them away on this
but it don't I need to ask you about
this oak is one of the things you've
learned is that he has now a withered
hand yeah which is an interesting irony
and the whole book how did it happen and
what impacts that had on him did you
know of yeah he tried out his wife
Doorly we just talked about tried
divorced him he tried to commit suicide
mark Hoffman in jail he took a huge
overdose sleeping tablets and he you
know passed out was in a coma and he lay
on his right side and crushed his whole
arm and it and that circulation was cut
off many hours 810 hours something like
that and that permanently damaged his
his right hand and as far as I know he's
not able to forge now as a result of it
he was also injured in a in a bomb blast
because and now I'm starting to give
away rather too good
because we don't have much time I
watched you go any farther with that but
because they a couple things I need to
ask you when it was it first-degree
murder that he was convicted no it
wasn't it was second-degree with when
he's eligible for parole he's ours were
for parole in 2006 and it's the New York
Times after all they started all this
have they reviewed your book no I'm
waiting for him so there had been a word
in the book and the in the newspaper
about so far at the time we're taping no
oddly enough of the The Washington Post
The Boston Globe many others have but
the New York Times seems to be staying
away I don't know why here's the cover
of the book our guest has been Simon
Worrell he lives on Long Island he's a
British citizen and he wrote a book
called the poet and the murderer thank
you very much thank you Brian it was a
pleasure